and that makes desean jackson number
three all time for 50-plus yard
touchdowns behind randy moss with 29 and
jerry rice with
36. and
desean jackson incredible a forgotten
man coming into the season three
touchdowns already that matches what he
had last year and ryan fitzpatrick
getting it done for the tampa bay
buccaneers 27 for 33 402 yards four
touchdowns one pick he has nine total
touchdowns in two weeks he's the first
buccaneers quarterback ever to throw
four touchdown passes in consecutive
games
and he's clearly their best option
even with jameis winston on his way back
from suspension he misses one more game
next monday night against the steelers
coach tony dungy will be added to the
buccaneers ring of honor at halftime of
that game the next day jameis comes back
i don't think he plays week four short
week at chicago bye week after that the
earliest we see him is week six and even
then how do you pull fitz magic off the
field i i agree i i think he's at least
earned the right to week six and maybe
beyond already just with the way he's
played these first two weeks but yeah
well last year we saw jameis winston had
issues connecting with desean jackson
down the field that was something that
that kind of hampered the offense all
season long ryan fitzpatrick is not
having any issues with that at all and
this team has weapons all over the
football field oj howard oh six
six five 260 pound tight end who runs
4-5 mike evans you know a 6'5 220 pound
receiver who runs 4-3 and then you got
desean jackson and then you got chris
godwin and their offensive line is past
protecting this year that's the other
thing you know how many times in the
last few years have we just seen their
the bucks o line just get absolutely
steamrolled and they did a good job
yesterday keeping the philadelphia
eagles off of ryan fitzpatrick for the
most part the eagles d-line right mike i
mean they make a mess of teams usually
and that just was not the case yesterday
and it's got me thinking this buck so
lines really got itself turned around
because last week the protection was
phenomenal against the new orleans
saints as well they've got the line
they've got the quarterback they've got
the receivers the weapons desean jackson
129 yards o.j howard had 96. mike evans
83. mike evans is the reason why these
other guys are getting single coverage
mike evans is the one who gets doubled
and desean jackson is the one who gets
to run free and maybe at some point the
pendulum goes the other way and evans is
going to explode but fitzpatrick will be
good enough to spot who's available
who's open who's getting the match match
up that is favorable and take advantage
of it the only thing is the running game
yeah they need to do something about the
run again yeah eight uh 16 attempts for
22 yards for peyton barber jacquez
rogers added 13 yards on five carries so
they they have to figure that out
because at some point they are going to
come up against a team that is able to
slow down that passing attack but maybe
not
maybe the buccaneers are going to keep
this going all year we if we thought
they'd be oh and three during the three
games that jameis winston missed and now
they're two and oh and the steelers
really have to worry about falling to o2
and one on prime time monday night
against the buccaneers because that's
gonna be i figure the bucket news will
be favored in that game i figured
there'll be a two or three-point
favorite in that game well
they probably will be at least i'm gonna
give them at least a one point favorite
something along that line but yeah the
steelers defense and uh the way they
played yesterday yeah this is not
patrick mahomes throwing the football
but the weapons are you know up there in
that class as far as what they can do
with big plays and like we were just
talking about if they can pass protect
against the steelers then yeah the
steelers have showed us nothing in the
secondary that's just eye-popping that
we go oh this is an unbelievable unit
they played good in week one
the steelers defense it was horrible
yesterday and the bucks are on a roll
and dirk hutter i think he's a guy that
we got to give a little credit to what
he does on the offensive side of the
ball yeah they haven't been running the
ball well but man he makes you defend
every inch of turf on the field as well
with his pass game design it's
aggressive they don't look for two yard
you know completions out of the
backfield or anything like that when
they drop back to pass they are looking
for 20 30 yard completions and they
strike fear into defenses that way
and uh they got their mojo going right
now in tampa and the eagles now one and
one they had three extra days to get
ready for that game yes nick foles
apparently on his way out carson wentz
there was a report yesterday i think
from espn
that
carson wentz will be cleared this week
that's the anticipation he'll be able to
play next week against the colts that
gives him a little bit of a mini
preseason they have the colt stats who
do they have week four before they have
the vikings come to town week five but
that would give carson wentz a couple of
games to get his sea legs right before
facing the vikings stats do you have
that offense offense is concerning
certain they got the titans see so yeah
i mean i don't want to take anything
away from the titans or the colts they
both won yesterday but it's not the
vikings and this gives carson once a
chance to play a couple of games before
the vikings come to town and then they
go to the giants they've got the
panthers they go to the jaguars they get
some tough games coming up week five
three week eight their buy is week nine
so i i think that this colts titans kind
of like mini preseason for carson wentz
may be a good way to get him ready for
the big games coming up hopefully the
offense is still a concern i mean it was
just too little too late yesterday foles
played better certainly and made some
plays but you know again let's remember
this buck's defense had no brent grimes
no vernon hargraves two of their best
players in the secondary two of their
best cover guys so they were out there
and the eagles of course fell behind 27
to seven made a valiant comeback to make
the game close and competitive but uh i
think again let's not underestimate the
value of carson wentz and his ability to
make huge throws down the field
escape the pocket extend plays all those
things you know can get teams over the
hump maybe in the first half when the
eagles offense was kind of stumbling
along
great quarterbacks can make a few plays
to jump start your offense to where
you're not behind 27 to 7 and i think
that's what they're missing right now in
philadelphia yeah and and you know how
different you feel about a team after
one game because week one all right here
we go the the eagles are still the
eagles and philly philly and finding a
way to beat the falcons and now you go
on the road a game that they spent the
entire offseason from april on thinking
hey this is a gimme we'll go beat up on
the buccaneers not so fast one and one
and a couple of easy spots coming up but
then like i said week five through week
eight very difficult for the eagles and
maybe maybe they're gonna realize that
they're not the team they were a year
ago
you